a Premium Membership at chess comm we'll
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you play turning every game into a
chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level